fusion as an energy source is very
attractive it would be a carbon-free
energy source that could power mankind
forever the challenge is is making
fusion work at the National Ignition
facility what we're trying to do is
overcome a natural barrier that Nature
has set up for atoms to fuse together
the idea behind fusion is the two atoms
that you try to put together those cores
have the same charge and they repel one
another just like the two parts of a
magnet tend to repel each other one of
our main goals is to achieve
thermonuclear fusion to start a fusion
fire in the laboratory like the process
that's going on in the Sun in order to
create those conditions on earth we have
to concentrate a tremendous amount of
energy in a very tiny volume and so
we've built the world's biggest laser so
this facility is the size of three
football fields it's filled with lasers
and we concentrate all those lasers into
a tiny target you know about the size of
tip of your pinky so this is an if
target this is the thing we put at the
center of the chamber in order to do an
experiment and all 192 beams hit this
target so 96 beams come in from the top
96 beams come in from the bottom and all
that energy ends up in this little tiny
target in order to start the fusion
reaction
if we do that in just the right way we
have calculations that say we should be
able to get more energy out than we put
into this implosion in light a fusion
fire that could actually power power
plants and put energy on the grid so
where we are today on the National
mission facility with regard to ignition
is we're creating a lot of fusion events
where we take atoms and we force them
together and we see the energy released
it's kind of like a sparking match being
applied to a bonfire you haven't yet
caught the fuel on fire in such a way
that the whole thing burns what you're
getting are isolated events happening
within the bonfire stack so we see the
beginnings of the sparks but we're not
there yet with the bonfire so we were
successful at showing fusion as feasible
from my point of view would be a
defining moment much like the
demonstration of flight with the Wright
brothers playing in a similar way if we
get ignition on NIF we've now harnessed
the same processes that power the Sun so
we will have the opportunity before us
to move from the very first beginnings
of fire where we hit stones together to
make sparks to harnessing the power of
the Sun that's an exciting possibility
for humankind
[Music]